the thing that deeply moves me about  cinema is to see 200 people in the mud  under the rain trying to create poetry  together and and so much effort so much  uh  work uh for art it's that deeply touched  me i put a red tape on the floor i said  i don't want no nurse mad narcissistic  ego on this side okay no my seriously  there's people that have a bad  reputations it's too tough to make a  film it's too difficult i prefer to work  with um i love  the more i think artists are interesting  the more humble they are very often like  someone like hugh jackman uh roger  dickens is a very very very humble man  you know but in the same time he's a  genius i mean i love to be to surround  myself by people that are there because  they love cinema not because they love  themselves you know it's like a  two different thing